from Singapore and he will talk about
higher order fluctuations in denser in
them graph models
[Music]
thank you very much
um well first thanks the organizers
Christian Remco Subic and Sofia for the
kind of vegetation and um
great Workshop so far
so I've I've added this uh subtitle
statistical aspects to the title because
I realized that kucharon was on this
project as well she's going to talk
about the same thing so I will therefore
focus a little bit more on follow-up
work with my PhD students um Lee Sean
and which is Cosmo in the statistical
parts of this whereas cushion will focus
more on the mathematical distributional
limit part of the project
so let me quickly
um talk a little bit I mean this is
mostly just notation because most of all
us here or all of us here uh know about
these things so we have G1 G2 and so on
so forth a dense graph sequence and
we'll fix F denote that as the the F
we're counting uh the subcraft density
of which we're interested in
and the subgraph density uh here again
is injective homomorphisms we are not
looking at induced subgroups such as
regular subgraph counts and that'll be
the notation here T sub F of g n
uh the usual model we're looking at the
Workhorse of dense graph limit theorem
is limit theory is we fix the graph on
Kappa I've realized there's various
traditions in the community what letter
we should use as a probabilist I'm
hesitant to use the capital W for that
because it's sort of I don't want to
waste letters on things that are not
random so I use Kappa for that
um that's why the tradition of bolabosh
and Riordan I think they introduced that
in their paper so I stick to that
um you won you n up to un I had uniforms
that will be the vertex labels and we
connect the vertices I and J with
property Kappa uij and that will be U.N
Kappa is this random graph
and of course the Cornerstone of the
theory one of the cornerstones is this
law of large numbers which says that's
this random graph sequence converges in
this uh in the metric space of graphons
to the back to the original Kappa that
we started with and in and that is can
be expressed in terms of the subgraph
densities converging
to this uh deterministic quantity
so
as a probabilist once you give me a lot
of large numbers I will ask the question
well what's the central limit theorem of
that so we're asking about fluctuations
of subgraph densities as a Next Step
um in this in this endeavor what's the
central limit theorem of dense craft
limit Theory and it's not quite clear
but this wasn't for a while so here's
some discouraging observation you're
taking Edge to any random graph so P now
so Kappa is just p
constant
You observe the following these subgraph
densities are perfectly correlated in
the limit okay and they all correlate
with the edge density so in that sense
it's discouraging because it's telling
us all the fluctuations are essentially
the same they're governed by The Edge
densities if you have more edges you
will have more triangles you will have
more four Cycles because we're in the
dense case that's that's ultimately a
reason
uh so that's that so if you wish you can
stop here and say well that's the
central limit theorem of random uh dense
graph limit Theory
these this object here the random
randomness is just a sum of independent
bernoullis they are not IID because the
graph fund is is uh
um you know be constant in this case it
is it's just by normal distribution in
general it need not be
okay for General graph phones it's a bit
more complicated
um
the there is not one
Randomness source of Randomness that
governs the whole thing
um
so well in general we'll have that the
subgroup densities are dominated by
functions by sums of this form so you
take your labels you take functions of
these labels which depend on F which can
depend on Kappa and those are the the
objects that will dominate so the
correlation need not be one anymore
because the G's can differ for different
F's
but
the observation is that fluctuations of
stock graph densities are essentially
dominated by the vertex label and I
think uh boshwar uh where is he
all there thank you uh yesterday's talk
uh mentioned this that's the sort of
that's that's the source of the
randomness that we're observing most in
general
is just the vertex labels I say in
general here because his talk was about
coming up with conditions these uh what
is it um
regularity conditions under which
uh the other randomnesses observed
sources of Randomness but in general if
you give me a random rough one if you
will that'll be the situation
uh well that's sort of disappointing
because if we do statistical testing
what what are we testing actually right
we so at the end of the day we want to
test edges connectivity we don't want to
test vertex labels so that's sort of in
some sense disappointing that this is
the case
but um so there's this work by Johnson
novitsky from the from the 90s and then
there was a big monograph uh by swantey
Johnson in 97 called the um
what is it um uh gaussian Hilbert spaces
where um he sort of discussed this topic
in great generality uh and she realized
that this uh there's a generalization of
use statistics which are called
generalized Q statistics where you allow
not just dependence on random variables
in index by one index but you can also
allow pairwise indices and in this case
they use our labels and the Y's are our
edges and you can represent subcraft
densities
um in this manner
the key result is that such statistics
allow for a hoofing type decomposition
except that it's more complicated in a
hurting type the composition here sort
of have a decomposition in terms of
um
rates of or rather orders of magnitude
of fluctuation and depending on whether
your kernels are degenerate or not and
for this kind of General use statistics
in some sense it's similar but it is
still more complicated because the
decomposition is more complicated at all
Give an example
um so I'd say Kappa to be this
um what I think
What's called the the bipodal
um graph on yesterday and so we have
Alpha Beta so let's dig two groups gamma
is the size of the first group so we
have Alpha Beta Delta this determine the
connection probabilities and you take
the edge density
very simple
you can decompose it in terms of random
variables
that I call V sub
this dot actually is a vertex it's a
subgraph of this Edge the trivial sub
graph of this head of this Edge graph is
just a vertex so that's what this dot
means it's it's a it's a trivial graph
of science one that's one statistic that
shows up and there's another one which
is V sub Edge okay that's a
decomposition and you can see this the
composition involves different rates so
here we have the constant okay if you
look at what n does this is one over
square root of n
this is 1 over n this is one over n to
the three halves and the same here one
over n to the three no sorry I got it
yeah uh sorry these two match this is
one a brand this is one of brand and
this is one of our n to the three halves
so I've scaled things in such a way that
VSOP
B sub Dot and V sub H are
centered okay and they have
standard deviation of variance only one
okay this would be normalized
and there are parameters in here Row one
and row two
these they are explicit because you have
an explicit graph on with a simple
structure and here are these two
statistics okay so now what are these
statistics
the V Dot is just involving the vertex
labels what we're essentially doing is
we're counting the number of vertices in
group one right that's just the
indicator that UI is less than gamma
centered so that's just counting how
many of the labels are in group one okay
and the sabatch is a centered stock
craft count what we're doing is we're
centering but pay attention to the fact
that the centering is conditional on the
vertex labels it's not an overall center
it's a centering conditional on the
vertex label that's important
okay
sorry it is well
there's a Randomness in the centering
the randomness there's no Randomness is
ETC for we dot
um that's right yes
yes so it because it's in some sense
conditional on the on the uh you're
right you're quite right um in that
sense this is not a conditional Center
yes the uh for this trivial one and when
the V sub doctor is not conditional but
for the others it's all conditional on
the vertex labels
okay so what in principle Basha was
looking at is that the question on the
which can on the which conditions
um
what is sort of the leading term in this
decomposition right if you look at this
you can tell now well
if Row 1 is non-zero that'll be the
leading term it will be order one over
square root of n right that determines
the fluctuations because these are all
smaller order
if Row one is zero it'll be the next two
terms that determine the the limiting
behavior and you can see that you can
read it off
well you know what V sub dot that's just
a sum of ID random variables so there'll
be a central limit theorem so this
converges to normal this one you can
make a dedicated guess it's not quite
IID because there's random centering in
here but you can make a educated guess
that it'll be gaussian as well so
ultimately what you have here if Row one
is non-zero we have a gaussian limit if
it's zero we have a limit that is a sum
of a chi-square and a normal
distribution that's exactly what Bashar
bushwa did yesterday in emotionality for
more General gruffles okay
um if you don't believe me because I
want to repeat this calculation by hand
sort of that's sort of weird that that
this tea is a badge that's sort of a sum
of of a few mixed binomial distributions
ultimately that's what it is the mixture
coming from how many vertices are how
many labels are in here how many labels
are in there so if you don't believe me
here's an example that's the case where
Row one is non-zero looks very gaussian
and as soon as we're always zero you
start to see the deviation from gaussian
distribution the scaling is different as
well
uh and you see sort of you see the the
chi Square coming in here makes this
whole thing asymmetric
it's so it's sort of counterintuitive
so what does it look like for triangles
the decomposition becomes more
complicated
um
I've written it down here in terms of uh
decreasing orders of magnitude of
fluctuation so r0 is just um the
expectation
and then we have different
orders of magnitude of fluctuation
and you'll see this picture here
so there's Again The Familiar statistics
V sub dot okay
um but there's new statistics showing up
um v subtriangle v sub 2 Star what are
these well again there are sums
involving
the
the centered indicators that's already
that we have that before but we have now
new sub statistics which are of this
from for example V sub triangle is a
what I call a centered triangle count so
it is again the product of these three
random variables but is now the centered
um
Edge indicators okay and the centering
is done conditional on the labels
okay and again Boswell's question
generally is
what are these constants okay now in
this case I can give you what the
constants are exactly because the
underlying grapher is a two by two block
graph one right very simple I can do the
calculations explicitly
but in general the question is far from
obvious what this what these constants
are and in this case it's also we have
just one chi-square but in general for a
general graph form like a smooth grapher
not a block Matrix block form you may
have an infinite sum of of chi squares
so this is far from trivial in general
so what we are proposing then
pardon
different how to skills
um how many do you have I think that's
how many skills do you have yes uh I
think that depends on the size of the
graph so the larger the sub graph is
your counting the further down you go in
the the composition but at some point it
stops so this is the full big
composition for triangles
it doesn't go it doesn't go finer than
that so it doesn't uh there's no finer
fluctuations Beyond this one over n to
the 2.5 Adrian if you were to prove
fluctuation theorems conditionally on
the
use
you can also read off from this which
would be the first term that would be
fluctuating you should be able to do
that yes I guess that's the first term
that has a y hat yes that's right that's
right so it will be this case
um it's not that one this is um not
random so this not random there's more
terms here that involve the the V Sub
sub edges and things like that you're so
quite right yes you can read it off from
here in principle and would that be an
interesting question
um I guess it would be except that we
took a different path which is instead
of looking at the soft cup densities
what we're proposing is why don't we
just look at these these
as the fundamental statistics okay the
centered subgraph counts are the
fundamental statistics
that's that's our proposal okay
so these are the statistics we're
looking at now
a little caveat maybe you see that some
of these V's
have pre-factors these pre-factors may
depend on the on the labels okay they
could be constants but they could also
be depending on the vertex labels
okay sometimes there's stuff here
sometimes there isn't okay this one the
V sub triangle is just a clean standard
subtract um
um
centered triangle counts whereas others
have these pre-factors
these pre factors involve the vertex
labels which we maybe don't want to test
we are interested in the in the edges so
what we propose is to take just these
without these prefectors okay so there's
no prefector here so it's just a clean
centered stock graph
density okay so what the answer novitsky
and Johnson in this monograph showed was
essentially that these all these
statistics converge jointly to a
gaussian distribution to multivariate
gaussian distribution so what we've what
we've added to that story is a rate of
convergence using Stein's method which
required the whole development of styles
method because these are sums of
uncorrelated random variables but
they're still dependent why are they
uncorrelated well you can read it off if
you take so this is a sub if you take
any of these two of these and you take
the product of them okay
as soon as there's one free Edge
that doesn't occur twice which is the
case for any any summon that is
different any any combination of indices
that is different you take two of them
you multiply there will be always at
least one free Edge
and then you take expectation well
that's just zero because that's standard
condition on the use okay and you only
get a non-zero value if you take the
same indices twice each Edge appears
twice even then the variance is
straightforward to calculate
because conditional on the
vertex labels the edges are still
independent
okay
so given a graph how do you actually
compute this if you don't know sorry if
you don't know
if
if you don't know Kappa and the labels
how do you come actually compute this
excellent question that'll be that
the subject the topic of the second half
of this talk
exactly so
let's look at statistic applications so
what do you do in practice okay
as I said the number one is we don't
need these pre-factors okay we're not
interested in the vertex label so let me
just ignore those if you want to
understand that the fluctuations of the
subgraph densities the classical ones
you need those as well
and we can prove I mean our Johnsons and
Nowitzki is an hour
um limit theorems hold over all of these
jointly so anyone you give to me the
jointly conversion so that's not that's
not the Restriction here it's just when
you do actual statistics you don't want
to you want to have these pre-factors
what what there's no need for that so we
just take the clean ones okay so
statistic applications number one let's
work with the normalized one so instead
of normalizing by the pre-factors I have
here
to make the Border one but it would just
divide by the variance which I can
calculate explicitly well that's just
the
the variance of this sum it's just the
sum of the variances because they're
uncorrelated right so just divide by
that and the variance of these guys are
easy to calculate okay that's just the
variance of a binomial very
straightforward
the pig are the edge probabilities okay
and now if you do use it as a tester
test yes but in your setting the p a i
AJ's or two random variables okay
next slide okay
um
so if you said as a test statistic the
the choices of f will determine what
your test is sensitive to right but so
you're quite right in practice the pij
are known
so you have to replace them by P hat IJ
so that's an estimate of the edge
probability between I and J and then you
that's the actual test statistic is
exactly what you said you place the pijs
by pi head okay
so that's the test statistic
now where do the pij come from well you
run a
random graph model fitting algorithm you
have let's say a stochastic block model
right you you try you have to Cluster
the the vertices into classes and then
you you take the you estimate the
connection probabilities and that will
ultimately give you a pij and you're
right the pijs the pij heads depend on
the Y's and so that's exactly what we're
trying to analyze
um in this project with my PhD student
does the central limit theorem still
hold for those statistics or statistics
for the pijs depend on the on the on the
graph itself
so let me talk a little bit on
interpretation now there's a downside to
the story of that nothing is for free
and including here
the interpretation of these statistics
becomes more tricky because they're not
subcraft entities they're centered
supportensities so how do we interpret
these now this one is sort of
straightforward right if if you're
Z hat subh is large that means you have
more edges than you would expect well
that's straightforward to interpret no
no problems there
let's say uh Z hat sub 2 Star how to
interpret that how can that value be
large well there's two ways to get that
one is you have too many two stars right
in that case the two indicators are
larger than expectation
and you get you get a positive value but
there's another way which is both are
built are zero they're non-existent in
which case you have two negative values
multiplied with each other you get a
positive value again so this Z value is
large if you have either too many two
stars or a lack
of two stars okay
so the interpretation becomes more
difficult
triangles again what does it mean to
have a large value for this statistic it
means you have either too many triangles
that give you a positive value
or you have the situation where you have
too often or more often than you would
expect you have that one Edge is on and
the other two are off okay that'll also
give you a positive value okay
so let's do a simulation study and see
how these things behave in practice
so Kappa here is a stochastic block
model with four groups and these are the
connection probabilities it's just
random values we've chosen
of course it's symmetric
and we look at n equals 200 vertices no
now what we've done you simulate this
graph okay and then you reconstruct the
community labels where we did in this
project that was with cusharon which I
said well let's just take an
off-the-shelf algorithm in r that does
that for us and it's just we took the
variation of em algorithm from this
package block models which does the
clustering and the estimation of the
probabilities for us at the
so that's a one-liner that does
everything and so we wanted to see how
these things behave and here are the
results so what am I reporting now what
you see here let's just focus let's say
on column two okay column two means the
algorithm has I told the algorithm to
fit two two communities okay
so the algorithm will find two
communities that it thinks
are suitable for for two by two
stochastic block model and then it
estimated the
correction probabilities
once I had that I calculated these
statistics and here they are these are
the values of the statistics okay
if
the estimated two by two block model
were the correct one or close to the
correct one I would expect these values
to be close to gaussian okay
which are not quite because they're a
little bit too large remember the
standard gaussians are 1.96 roughly
should be the 95 percent
upper and lower bounds so this would be
too large but as you see if we go
towards the correct value 4 because
that's what we started with now you can
see these values are all within what you
would expect for a standard gaussian and
they're independent so there's no in the
limit if that's a on the null hypothesis
they're also independent of each other
so they're very easy to interpret
okay black is the column that the
algorithm gave us back and and and said
well the algorithm believes black is the
correct number which is correct for
what's the on the line correct number
and so everything is fine this is a
consistent picture for the simulation
study but we know the ground truth
any questions so far
I haven't shown yet that if REM was
asking well you haven't shopped you
haven't shown that that Z hat is
gaussian or that they're independent I
haven't shown that yet at this point of
the project it was just a simulation
story
okay
but but also I mean if you were to do
this in practice right so so yeah this
is in practice because that's an actual
Network
yeah no no I was just thinking about the
simulations
I'm a problem let's who cares
the first three you're going to be
rejecting but it's a multiple testing
hypothesis right so if you're
yeah you're right so you're absolutely
right so if you want to do independent
so you can still do that so the fourth
one is the first one that you would not
reject correct but then you could go
higher up right so so would you take the
first block size where you don't reject
your number yeah if I if I was a
decision because I'm not I'm a
probabilist as well so if I worked at
this we can talk to each other
you're right so you would have you would
do this and then stop at the point where
you whether whether statistic no longer
becomes
um significantly
um away from from what you hypothesized
it should be under the null hypothesis
but you're right there's a multiple
testing problem here that you would have
to take care of
and so on so forth of course for one up
to three these values have no reason to
be independent because
the null hypothesis is wrong it is not a
three by three or two by two okay
from here onwards they're sort of
independent
if if
we can extend the theory to replacing
the pijs by pi
um by pij hats and it's still gaussian
and independent in the limit so here's a
real example
no no we have to prove it we have to
prove it because if you have more groups
and it may be that you're somehow
splitting them in a bad way let me
Backtrack on the statement okay it is
not obvious it seems plausible but not
obvious you're right
um
okay so this is a real Network 75
participants This was
um data taken in the hospital in 2010 in
France in hospitals 75 participants
there was a nurses doctors patients were
wearing these uh sensors and the um they
would record when people are near each
other for um for a certain while and so
what we do is I mean the data set
consists of all the encounters and we
just say okay two people are connected
if they ever encountered each other
during this three-day period
of observation so okay so we ran the
algorithm
here's the multiple so the different
groups that you need if you stick figure
stochastic block model
um and black is again what the algorithm
gave us back to be the correct number so
now we can do diagnostics okay we can
say okay let's look at how this model
performs
in terms of representing local graph
statistics and you can see it doesn't
perform well okay
in particular Cycles
let's look at this the cycle the four
Cycles the three Cycles they're sort of
off as well as stars okay
I'm not saying there are too many four
Cycles there's something for wrong with
the four cycle structure now I have to
think about how do you get a large value
for Z well too many four Cycles is one
way to get it but it could also be two
on two off that's also where you get a
positive value okay
but that's that's the sort of a next
that we're not there yet in terms of
okay let's do like routine statistical
um analysis of this data how what in
what ways you need to interpret these
things I mean that we're not there yet
this is just sort of
the first step towards that goal
okay so even if you fit eight groups it
doesn't really match so so the takeaway
here is this data is not well reflected
by stochastic block model that's what
that would mean at least from the
perspective of local
statistics
okay some theoretical properties and now
we're coming back to the P hat okay so
we thought okay let's start simple so we
um
let's assume we have a k by K stochastic
block model and let's assume that labels
are known okay then we can calculate the
mle
estimator sorry the east or is that for
estimator the the maximum likelihood
estimator of the edge densities is
straightforward because it's just a
binomial distribution if the number of
edges between two groups is binomial and
so the mle estimator is just the ratio
of edges versus the maximum number of
edges you could have
so that's so in that sense the estimator
is explicit as a side note if you do
that the the edges are always perfectly
matched okay if that's your estimator
your uh Z sub Edge statistic will be
zero
so we'll not have a gaussian limit
okay
um so what we have shown that's the
follow-up work is that if you um fix
your F okay these statistics now have a
slight bias that comes from the
dependence in your pis Pi heads they're
dependent on the edges weekly but they
are dependent and there is a bias as a
result and here's the bias it depends on
F so the worst case is the two star
which has a bias of um one over square
of n which sounds not too bad but if
your graph is like 200 or a few hundred
the constant is not small but maybe 10
or something it starts to influence your
statistic if you do
um well we see that it'll influence your
statistics so
it's an important finding that to
exclude your two-star statistic if your
graph is not too large so here's an
example
uh I've simulated this
um I don't remember what it was I think
it was the one from before the this K
that I showed you this 4x4
um graph phone this is a realization of
that I think 800 realizations so each
dot is one is the realization of one
graph I don't remember what the size of
the graph was n the number of vertices I
don't remember a few hundred
um you can see there are at least on the
bivariate picture they're all very
gaussian but you can see that the
the two of course the edges is just zero
right that's what I just said the two
stars statistic is slightly biased to
the left and if you take the average
here over all these two star statistics
you can see there's a bias of minus two
uh minus 0.25 the other statistics
example if okay they're close to zero
but that one is clearly biased enough to
be concerned about it
okay so we want one step further and
said well let's look at
on top of that now let's do the the
clustering finding Community labels and
we just said okay let's take a let's
take an off-the-shelf algorithm in this
case spectral clustering that gives us
the community labels and then on top of
that we do the mle to estimate the
connection probabilities and see how
what's happening and we found we've
tested various models we found that the
spectral clustering doesn't seem to be
performing well on the core periphery
structure which means you have part of
the graph is dense highly connected and
there is a periphery Which is less
connected of course in the dense setting
everything stands but
your spectral clustering is that okay
are you asking me the details about the
implementation of this I'm asking what
suspect or clustering is because there
could be you look at sort of four
eigenvectors and just use them to
Cluster or you could look at just the
top two eigenvectors as a second
eigenvector split in half and again
split in half in a second step so um
that's a good question
um
I don't remember the details so the
we're taking the let's say you want to
fit you want to find K communities you
take the top K eigen vectors and use
those as a basis
um for clustering so you take a k
um came in clustering or something of
that sort
um I don't remember the details to be
honest
um we tried to be off the shelf and
since this is fairly standard there's
nothing fancy here so I know there's
very embellished a lot of embellishments
of this of these algorithms there might
well be that certain types of
embellishments Works in this case well
but the ones that we've used off the
shelf
seem to have problem with the core
periphery structure
um if the graph has this kind of
structure yes
so we consider three regimes
um yes right I don't I'm not sure I
understand what you just said are you
generating data using some kind of a
model where core bravery is the No No
sorry let me be clear the underlying
mode is still the same prefer mode
corporatory means I've chosen the values
here in such a way that we have highly
connected 0.8 highly connected but
either that's two cores
and then we have two communities which
are not really communities they have an
Insight within the community
connectivity of point one
okay but they're highly connected to
this core okay and we have two of these
okay
now we're still in the dense setting in
some sense they're still all dense
but the structure I mean I understand
okay
you you can't this is not really
Community because they're more connected
to this community than they're connected
among each other so that's what makes
this what's called a core periphery
structure
that's it
and that's why Spectra clustering might
not find these correctly yes I agree
with that
but if you don't know the graph in
advance you wouldn't be able to tell
that's that's the issue right
but by Miss I mean it's being used for
stochastic block model
um
clustering so it's not not something
that is out of the uh
so we've looked at three cases uh the
dense case which is does that's the
graph form given by these connection
probabilities we have an intermediate
and a somewhat more sparse case where we
divide the probabilities by n with
various powers to sort of see how these
things perform on in the non-dense case
the test statistic is just the you take
these statistics here
um have I already shown that these
things have I mentioned that they
converge to gaussian have I mentioned
that
yes okay sorry I didn't forgot to say
that they're not they're biased a little
bit but I forgot to say that they're
still multivariate gaussian and
independent in the limit so the
dependent is not strong enough to screw
things up too much on the under these
mle estimators okay
except that the the two-star statistic
is biased so we exclude that
okay
so we calculate the chi-square statistic
which is the square of these three
subgraph centered subgraph densities
okay we've excluded to two star because
I said it's too biased for for the
number of vertices we're looking at and
if you
if you assume the null hypothesis is
true that means if you assume that these
are independent gaussians and the
chi-square statistic should have a
distribution which is chi-square with
five degrees of freedom and from that
you can calculate the p-value so what we
did we calculated a bunch of p-values uh
using this and if the null hypothesis is
true these p-values should be uniformly
distributed on the unit interval if
you're not they're probably biased
towards zero okay so let's quickly look
at how this spectral clustering
algorithm performs if you have enough
vertices it still performs well so what
we're reporting here is the number of
correctly identified correctly labeled
vertices if you see for example n is 800
then spectral clustering still performs
okay right 99 of the vertices are
correctly classified of course if you go
to the sparse regime where you have
fewer edges
you have lots of information and
therefore you would expect that your
classification probably comes harder
0.25 is the lower bound this is random
guess because we have four communities
right so lower gas lower bound is 2.5
that's 0.25
and of course if you have fewer vertices
you also have a a loss of information
but in general spectral clustering can
solve the job if you have enough
vertices
so this is okay what we've looked at
here is is uh I'm not sure I have enough
time this is sort of 40 minutes now so
let me give you a few more minutes
um
so we here we're measuring how far away
the p-value is from a normal from a
uniform distribution we just take the L1
distance of the cumulative distribution
function of the P values which is just
the area between
the uh empirical cumulative distribution
function and the and the straight line
from zero to one okay
and so if you know the labels if you
know the underlying probabilities that's
the sort of that's you know everything
then this value should be small because
it your P values are close to the
diagonal I mean the CDF are close to the
diagonal that means you're roughly
uniformly distributed that's all fine
if I know the labels but I don't know
the probabilities that means I estimate
those you will have expect some loss of
precision which is correct here
um
as you can see they are still small a
bit larger because you have a bit more
fluctuation a bit more uncertainty
and then you use factual clustering on
top of that you see suddenly Things
become much worse that means in many
cases the P values are way too small
that's the reason why you have these
values close to one that means the P
values are essentially many of them are
zero and then you have so it means your
empirical CDF goes up and then stays
close to one so that'll give you
um well this is two times that distance
so that's the worst you can have is a
half but then you multiply by two you
get one as the maximum worst case value
so we try to understand why is that wise
yes
the previous slide I mean going from a
equals 200 up to 800 for the first two
rows labels in Canal and and also the
second you know like the middle value in
the intermediate case is always
decreasing is there any intuitive reason
why the spectral clustering from here to
here to Here
Yeah from like 0.98 to 0.77 it's
decreasing like um
here it's increasing right here
um yeah it's always decreasing for the
for the I think for the sparse when it's
increasing so again but for the for the
for the intermediate it's increasing
that's fine for the dense one it's
decreasing right it goes from one one
point to 0.88
I think the reason being is that if it
gets it wrong it gets it wrong quite
badly so if the p-value is off it'll be
just very close to zero that's why you
get these
I'm 100 we haven't done a very rigorous
analysis it's sort of
what my students sent me if you uh
within the last week so that's that's
the state of analysis so what we've done
here is
extracted some cases
um where the algorithm is doing well in
general so here is the correctly
classified number of vertices from the
spectral clustering as you can see all
everything is correctly classified and
then you expect these values to be like
independent gaussians which they are
okay
here is a situation where you get one
wrong one out of I think this is 800. so
one out of 800 is wrongly classified and
suddenly you can see that these
statistics detect that okay and if you
calculate the p-value out of this of
course it's going to be essentially zero
okay because the case this is
this is very far away from zero
that's why you get this very extreme
um
deviations for for the p-value what I
like about this is the following
is detectives
okay they can see that only one has been
wrongly classified
not only that it tells you something
about the structural problem when you
look at which values are large it's the
stars that are large okay and that's
exactly what you would expect in a core
periphery structure that you have a lot
of these Stars okay so Stars play an
important role in that model and you can
see that
two star three star four star these are
the large values the Cycles are
essentially unaffected you can see the
Cycles are still fine there's nothing
wrong with the cycles
okay even this one with a little
appendix which is sort of it has a
little bit of a star structure even that
one is okay all right
that's why I mean you can see from here
in some sense it tells you something
about the structural issues where the
Fate went wrong
okay
um what we also did later on is that
okay can we then use this subgraph
density
idea to improve the clustering so we did
that so we have
um I don't remember what the details
here were I mean what n is but it's
again four by four we have this core
periphery structure we we calculate the
the chi-square statistic for different
group sizes and these are the chi-square
values as you can see they're all
essentially
you can tell that the model doesn't fit
either way so what you can do then is
you take this as an input
and see whether can we switch some of
the class labels to improve the
chi-square statistics so to improve on
the clustering to better reflect the
local structure and if you do that
um so here by the way the correctly
classified number is 83 percent
correctly classified for for this case
four by four because that's a grand
truth that we can calculate how many
have been correctly classified
if you run an algorithm that sort of
greedily reassigns labels to reduce the
chi-square statistic and you do that
step step stepwise until you cannot
improve any further
that's the picture of course one class
has nothing to do because it's just one
class everyone has the same label right
nothing Improvement here of course but
when you go down you suddenly see that
there's a big jump from three to four
was an indication that the subcraft
statistics
can pick up what the correct number
should be
for for this model okay
and then we can of course improve
further it's this is still significant
so you have to go further to to like
maybe you would choose five or six
um groups to to properly okay I would
love to ask more questions but actually
I have to speak up to tell you that you
should all right
so yeah okay so pros and cons
they're easy to calculate in general
um they can be used for testing proper
testing because you can calculate
p-values you can use them for clustering
the downside is if you will you need
these values these estimated values and
in they can be more computationally
expensive to calculate than the regular
Soft Rock Counter 26 in the sparse case
at least
and the interpretation is of course not
as straightforward because now you have
to think about what is a large Z value
for triangles mean you have to think
about that a bit more careful okay thank
you very much
apologies for the uh overtime
so maybe while the next speaker sets up
you can take a few more questions
yes
oh Peter just doesn't need to set up he
just will speak extemporarily from the
back
right
so uh I have a okay
yes so uh for the asymptotic results
that you mentioned so you mentioned that
the you use some stance method so are
they like finite uh Sam so finite
guarantees for that result yeah it's a
final result
okay so there are explicit guarantees
that depend on W
depend on the graph one yeah yes yes
so our next speaker will be Peter
originally from Germany then from uh New
York and now